When we know what we're good at,...
...and use those skills regularly, our lives improve.
We feel more confident about ourselves, and that confidence makes us happier.
We also have a chance to share these skills with others by doing work of value,...
...and earn money doing the things we love most.
One way to find out what you're good at is by thinking about your talents.
What are the things that come naturally to you?
Maybe it's writing, or cooking, or creating something new.
Perhaps it's working with children or animals,...
...or maybe it's being a math whiz.
Whatever your strengths are,...
...think about how often you use them...
...and whether there are ways you can use them even more.